all right guys
bang bang you're in for a treat
raul's here uh thank you so much for
doing this again sir
i'm i was looking forward to when he
reached out i thought this will be fun
so last time we did this we did this in
new york uh we did it in march i think
we were one week
uh early to the government mandated
lockdowns
uh the chronovirus kind of mania and uh
you had a pretty grim message
uh but one that ended up being uh fairly
accurate
in terms of a lot of things that were
gonna transpire let's just start
with what has happened since march right
so we have the government lockdowns how
do you view kind of the macroeconomic
landscape
uh over the last cause six to eight
months yeah so
if you remember when we spoke we talk
about this three-part
three-phase that happens over these kind
of crises one was that liquidation phase
which
happened almost immediately i left your
office right so that
that that happened that finished in the
end of march
then we had what i called the hope phase
and the hope phase was when everybody
thought it was going to be okay
and we saw that there was a big lift in
asset prices
everyone thought it's okay and then i
said it's going to transition to the
insolvency phase and that's where we
start to see
the drag on gdp growth going forwards
and that in itself would start to see
people get laid off again the stimuluses
disappear
small businesses go under and that
process unfolding
so let's look back and put okay how did
that do so the hope plays
dead right now what surprised me is the
hope phase in markets never went away
yes the bond markets were different the
banks traded differently so
we saw this bifurcation people call it
the k-shape but really
the markets kept hope while the
underlying economy
you know whether it's europe or whether
it's the u.s has kind of slowed down
again
so we're still seeing exactly as my
thesis year-on-year gdp growth like
negative five percent negative four
percent
everyone focus on that q1q number of hey
gdp is up 34
no everybody's having a really [ __ ] time
of it
and you know the dichotomy between wall
street and
the average guy is something i've never
seen in my life before i mean it's
simply staggering
but that's where we are um we're in that
situation now where
this virus is going to continue longer
than expected
you know we're going to get another
spike after thanksgiving travel in the
u.s
then we've got to go into christmas and
new year i
in the us they're never going to tell
people not to do christmas or new year's
eve parties
so by the time biden gets it in february
he's going to be
peak virus and there's a decent risk
that
there that the us is really going to
have to
to shut down various parts of the
economy to get this under control while
they roll out the vaccines
in europe the situation has already
happened so they made the mistake of
reopening over the summer let everyone
go on summer holiday
everyone goes down to spain gives each
other the virus comes back and explodes
genius so the europeans are now fighting
it they've had to lock down
it's been pretty clear by everybody from
the germans to the english to the swedes
that
nobody's really going to properly reopen
until march or so
so we've got this situation where the
global economy and and it looks like
christmas is going to get cancelled in
europe you know
kovit is going to be the the grinch that
stole christmas
and that's in europe huge spending
so the economy is going to be weak it's
going to be weaker for longer all of
those
shops and your hairdressers and
restaurants all of that stuff that rely
on christmas and new year
it's done so that's the situation we're
in
we're seeing the rise in asia we're
seeing slow down in asia as well it's
not as bad
yes we know the deaths aren't as high
but it's not about deaths
it's about your mum taking evasive
action staying at home
not spending you're not going to see her
for christmas not bringing a bunch of
presents with you
not bringing you know your siblings
there it's just natural human behavior
so
everyone just needs to ignore the
politics of it it's just humans and we
just do the same kind of thing which is
we're risk averse
and governments are risk-averse too so
that's the situation we're in
so i think we've got a pretty ugly patch
coming up who knows what the markets do
the markets want to look through it
but the the outcome of all of this and
crucially to the conversation we're
going to have is
okay we missed an entire stimulus in the
u.s
which is the one from september never
got done
and a bunch of stuff's about to roll off
in december as well so
it's a wily coyote moment for everybody
where you're off the end of the cliff
and there's nothing beneath you until
the new administration gets in and they
can try and get a similar package
through
but we don't know what's going to happen
to georgia we don't know whether they're
going to get the senate
are they going to get through a stimulus
package or not who knows
right so it's a messy situation europe
they're going to have to stimulate again
um how
well the ecb said they're going to do
something because inflation is negative
and falling
but the governments themselves can't
italy's already applied
to say can you write off some of this
debt nobody knows how they're going to
deal with this
nobody knows how the banking system is
going to work so you've got the central
banks trying to support this whole
situation because fiscal stimulus is not
happening
and the problem is the monetary
mechanism doesn't work so velocity of
money
every single major country in the world
outside of the u.s is now below one
and the u.s is 1.2 or somewhere so
basically money from central banks
doesn't go through the banking system
and into the economy and works
so that's kind of what i think is coming
obviously through the back of that
we then get the recovery it's that's a
standard recession at some point
things look good again and then we look
for the macro trends
that emerge from that how do you think
about
uh kind of the early stimulus packages
right so we had like you know three plus
trillion dollars
um and then we got towards the end of
the year and
you know basically politics took over
but in terms of the actual response
kind of in march and into april if you
had to give a grade was that a
a plus response a c minus somewhere in
between like how do you just think about
what the federal reserve and elected
officials did
i thought it was the fastest response
i've ever seen to something that was a
severe
shock i mean it's the biggest shock you
and i are ever going to live through in
our
lifetimes in terms of the economy you
know um
and they were quick and they were pretty
big everybody did it
the problem is it was all and i this
what i mentioned
and i've been talking about it was all
short term so
nobody figured out that this was going
to last longer which was what i talked
about when i
saw you last it's like this is a longer
event than people imagine
so what happened is everything started
rolling off and then in the u.s
it's so political to try and get
anything done it stopped so
they did a great job you know the
federal reserve
like it or not stop the credit market
imploding um
if the credit market imploding that's
the pension system gone and they stopped
it yeah
it's not good that they are ending up
buying microsoft debt and all that kind
of [ __ ]
you know it doesn't make sense but i
understand speed was of the essence at
that point in time
now what they've done is basically
destroyed the monetary mechanism for the
credit markets
um and everything else in the interim
because they've basically supported
everything
yeah and so when you think about kind of
this intervention
i think there's a lot of people who say
hey i don't like it but they had to do
it
they did it that's the situation that
we're in i've been calling it almost
like bridge the gap stimulus meaning
that they basically wanted just enough
stimulus until the recovery happened and
then
they could bridge that gap or that
detraction in the
economy obviously if it's longer than
you expect and you don't get more
stimulus done then you don't bridge the
gap you just
fall in the canyon kind of halfway
through which is kind of where we are
but what that does is it changes the
investor landscape and you
recently had this thread that uh went
viral around the death of
macro right and uh what it seems like
is that intervention overlaid with
all sorts of long-term trends that are
now kind of all meeting or intersecting
has led to this conclusion but maybe
let's just start with like what do you
mean when you say
there's the death of macro so
as a macro investor what do you trade
what do we do we look at economic
signals
and look for dislocations in markets
where we can profit from those economic
trends or dislocations
and that means generally trading
top-down asset classes as opposed to
picking stocks like microsoft or
whatever it is
so we're looking at currencies and bonds
the two biggest and most liquid markets
on earth
commodities because they tend to work
according to the economic cycle
things like precious metals they work
according to the monetary cycle
and equities which are the least macro
because they're all based on human
behavior
um generally so and credit markets is
the other one
so okay that's the rule book so whether
you're stan drucker miller george soros
any macro legend how have you actually
made your money
on the real vision interview with stan
drucker miller he made it very clearly
says everyone thinks it's all about
stocks and all that stuff he goes i made
all my money in bonds
they all have right i mean i've been in
this business since 1990
and bond yields have fallen ever since
and
you know you've only had one serious
pushback um
and they've actually been falling since
1982 so everybody's career stand rucker
mills is included
there has been one trade why bonds well
because bonds
actually give you high returns with very
low volatility
so risk adjusted returns are amazing
which means you can take
massive leverage so when things like the
economy slows down
bonds rally and bond yields fall
and that kind of 18-month period between
the start of a recession
afterwards is when you make enormous
returns they all do they all have that's
macro for you
and bond yields are now at zero
everywhere and i think the us probably
ends up with negative rates at the end
of this too
much like the uk just went negative over
the over um
you know uh the autumn so we're negative
to zero interest rates
so basically there's no juice left in
that trade
so the biggest trade in the world is
gone
okay credit i'm not much of a credit guy
because you need a bit more knowledge of
the underlying
you know credits themselves but if
you're trading credit as an asset class
as many macro guys do
well the fed and the ecb just stopped
that game as did the boj
they basically said we're not going to
allow the credit markets to price risk
because we can't and the reason being is
we have this old population
and they've got all their money and
pensions if you wipe out the pensions
you wipe out the savings of the baby
boom generation which is the largest
generation on earth
so that's not going to happen so now you
don't have a credit market
and you've seen triple b credits are now
all-time low yields again
in the middle of an insolvency event
brilliant so
no mechanism to price the equity market
basically total was strained so the
equity market people said
well look let's look at tech stocks they
kind of look like you know
um perpetual bonds or zero coupon bonds
because
they generate cash they've got no debts
so we can price those to infinity
because where else we put our money i
get it is that right or wrong
i don't know the macro guys are all
trying to figure it out but they're very
nervous of the equity market because
nobody understands this new paradigm is
it real or not
but then the big one is coming and
that's the depth of the currency market
that's something that i've been talking
about if that goes then macro is
finished because currency like bonds is
enormous super liquid you know
trades for three or four trillion a days
it dwarfs anything else
now what we've heard from the imf the
bis
the bank of japan the bank of england
the ecb
the fed people's bank of china
and everybody is this move to digital
currencies and i'm sure we'll get a bit
more about that
in a bit but what's been clear
is the imf are pushing for an agenda
which is the new bretton woods
and bretton woods was an agreement
amongst nations
basically to pedal their currencies to
the to gold
and then famously nixon came off the
gold standard eventually
but that was a post-world war ii
construct that allowed
all nations to kind of not compete with
each other on interest rates to build a
platform of which
once they built britain woods they built
everything from the united nations
to the world banks the imf and all of
these institutions that we know
so if the imf is saying it's what are
they saying
so i've gone through their speeches and
they're basically saying
okay we're in an extraordinary situation
right now
countries need to print money
to fiscally stimulate as we talked about
earlier but
it's kind of difficult to do it and if
you fiscally stimulate
the amount that you actually need to
let's say do proper stimulus not just
giving a check
but creating jobs by creating industries
and all of those
things that need to happen well that's
like 20 or 30 or 40 percent of gdp they
need to do
how do you do that without devaluing
your currency and the answer from the
imf is
do it all together if you do it together
then what are you devaluing against well
hard assets bitcoin gold stuff like that
but you're not developing each other
you're not winning terms of trade
this is the idea that facebook libra had
which is create a basket of currencies
where the dollar is one of the
currencies it's not the denominator so
if you think of everything else it's
like euro against dollars yen against
dollars
what they're talking about is having the
dollar in the basket
if you do that then the denominator is
money supply
so it becomes a very stable thing
because
money supply yes at times it goes a lot
but it doesn't grow that much
so then what you're basically doing is
dampening currency volatility down to
zero
and so in that world um let's say that
we play this out and they actually
successfully create
you know a basket of existing sovereign
uh or nation-state-backed fiat
currencies
uh and there's kind of this
quote-unquote one-world currency right
however you want to think about it
one that kind of removes all competition
between countries right in terms of
interest rates and all of that but two
how does that change what i'll call just
the management of
monetary policy at the individual
country level is there still
some level of sovereignty and each
country can kind of do
uh certain things within parameters or
does it almost get consolidated
in um some sort of like global central
bank type
situation don't forget britain woods was
essentially a consolidation
but interest rates countries still need
to borrow and lend and there is an
interest rate market
so it's not what the ecb is doing which
is creating a single currency
what it is is creating a currency basket
of which currencies move around and
change their weights within it
so it's more like the s p than it is
the euro so it is different
but i think it opens interesting
dynamics of
okay let's say they do this let's say to
be a member nation of this
bank core which is what keynes talked
about
back before bretton woods he said why
don't you do this it's basically the
same idea roughly
so to be a member let's say okay all
members are allowed to print 50
of gdp this year all together
so everybody does their printing
everyone does their fiscal stimulus
after you do that you're limited to two
percent money supply growth
or if not you're out of the basket so
you get worse trade terms
okay well that's interesting because
then you're actually turning it into
something that has a limited money
supply right that actually looks a bit
more like bitcoin
obviously not in many ways but in terms
of supply now
will nations cheap will it all go wrong
of course you know
they're central banks of course but you
know there's interesting mechanisms that
they can create out of this
and i think there was a tweet that sahil
bloom put out today about the overton
window
this is an overton window basically
anything is up for grabs
much like it was after the 1930s when
all of these institutions were built
and after world war ii anything can
happen right now
and this is fascinating you know this
whole central bank digital currency
thing that's going to lead us into a
whole new world but
the death of macro seems like
it could be a reality now obviously
that's slightly flippant because macro
moves around into different areas now in
a world like that what does it mean for
emerging markets it's probably
exceptional
because let's say you're south africa
you get killed every time the dollar
goes up and you can't export your goods
and all of that sort of stuff
but if you have a stable currency to
trade in
well you're going to do much better so
it's probably incredibly positive for
emerging markets okay that's interesting
you know what does it mean for commodity
markets well maybe they become less
cyclical
um how can how the countries compete
with each other
i don't know it's probably technology
it's you know how do you attract capital
in that world when it's not interest
rates necessarily
you know it becomes really interesting
as a as a thing and you know
and then how does obviously bitcoin and
gold and stuff like that fit into that
really interesting so macro could shift
it
maybe it doesn't but there's a once in a
lifetime
not even a lifetime a once in a century
opportunity
to change the construct of the system
now
whether it's any better or not i think
it'll be better
but it won't solve the problems money is
a bigger problem itself
for sure and i think one of the most
interesting things is uh as this kind of
death of macro trend
uh accelerates and becomes kind of more
real uh what we're starting to see is
many of the quote-unquote legends of
wall street who really are just macro
traders who have done very well for
themselves
uh one by one they're raising their hand
and um
you know kind of revealing their
interest intrigue and positions
in crypto in general right usually it's
bitcoin they start with but
but kind of you see everyone starting to
uh
not just do it but be public about that
position to
go on television and talk about that
bullishness that they have behind the
trade
um let's start with bitcoin i think last
time we talked you were
kind of single digit percentage uh
exposure to bitcoin
and then you had kind of uh what i'll
call traditional uh portfolio but
traditional for
for you versus others um now you are
uh 98 of your liquid net worth
is invested in uh crypto i think it's 80
bitcoin 20
ethereum let's just start with like what
changed or or
what were the things that went into you
going from single-digit percentages
to uh more than majority uh and kind of
almost all of your liquid liquid net
worth being so bullish on
uh on bitcoin and ethereum and again
look i'm a macro guy so i don't expect
anybody to follow me
you know you do the same with your
allocation you're looking at it from a
macro perspective
other people can't take the risks but
for me
i looked at the situation all outcomes
for me were
now this is it rarely happens
let's say i'm right deflation is
persistent the economy is worse than
expected
we don't get rid of this whole economic
mess until let's say q3 next year
okay so the answer to deflation and
slow economy is printing of money and
more fiscal stimulus
okay let's then push that aside and say
no raoul's a total idiot is completely
wrong
the markets are right inflation is
everything
in an inflationary market well bitcoin
and gold do well
so here we've got a smile where the
least likely outcome which is
everything just returns back to kind of
one and a half percent two percent gdp
growth and
we all forget it's just happened that's
not going to happen it's simply not
going to happen
maybe it does but that's the risk that
we all run in the bitcoin position
so basically inflation deflation of any
sort if we look at
all the past episodes what it was 2008
2012 in europe when europe
almost went under and then periodically
afterwards the central bank kept
stimulating didn't stop
they're not going to stop here so
that to me is a good setup okay so i've
now got a good case so then
the case is okay at that point i said
right gold bitcoin
those are my main bets i own some bonds
because i'm a deflationist
and i had some dollars because and some
other trading positions
okay fine so then what changed is the
charts
you know we'd all been looking at it
that the chart of bitcoin was this
beautiful beautiful wedge pattern
triangle pattern and it broke so of
course i'm
i'm a macro guy i can see an opportunity
i can see a great chart when i see one
i start saying right look we've got to
get we've got to add to this
and you know i added obviously into the
big sell-off as well because i saw this
pattern emerging
so then it breaks i start adding okay so
now i'm over 50
and just real quick what were you
selling initially
to move capital what was there a
specific asset or were you just going
across
all assets and kind of reducing trading
positions because i just saw that this
one
had the propensity to make more money
than anything else
but then it got to the point where you
start looking at the charts and i
started digging into the charts and
writing about it in global macro
investor
looking at the comparisons of bitcoin
versus all other assets
and i started tweeting about this and
this is before it really started
happening
i'm like look at these charts bitcoin is
about to eat the world
right looks like it's going to become
the super black hole
of which it's going to outperform every
single asset class another
i've never seen this before literally
i've never seen it you know we've seen a
gold might be dominant but you might
have bought copper instead blah blah
blah
there's nothing nothing not even mostly
amazon and stuff like that
looks like it's going to outperform
bitcoin so that's when i start saying
okay
this is the time to really go for it
because it's a waste of capital
to put it into anything else now i'm not
coming at this with the philosophy
you know the bitcoinization of the world
or anything else i'm coming it here as a
macro guy
saying i've never seen a more dominant
opportunity
in my entire lifetime and if that is the
case
it's time to really back your bet
absolutely
and so i think it's a good opportunity
one of the things that
i really enjoy when i talk to you is you
talk to lots of different people right
so you talk to people in the bitcoin and
crypto world you talk to people in kind
of the traditional investing world
uh many of your friends are some of the
best macro investors in the world some
of the most famous investors
and then you've got a lot of
conversations that go on in the
institutional world
i think most people know what's going on
in the bitcoin and crypto world and the
traditional investing world
in the private conversations you're
having with whether it's friends in the
macro world or in the institutional
world
what is being said in those
conversations and i don't necessarily
want to know from who
but just what's kind of the behind the
door conversation
around the macro environment and bitcoin
uh specifically and kind of how people
are viewing this
so the macro environment
you rightly alluded before almost
everybody i know
has a personal allocation to bitcoin
now dan moorhead was first to understand
that this was going to
be all other assets and then it sucked
in you know one after the other on
probably john burbank was probably next
and then you know
novo and it just starts you know
taking people in people
people don't understand that you guys
are all friends right they don't
understand that there's an entire uh i
call it generation of macro investors
that basically grew up together
and uh kind of you know went through
their careers and somehow
it went from you know one trade to the
next stage to the next trade and when
bitcoin became an opportunity
literally it just walked down this
entire kind of loose collection of
friends
until everyone had exposure yes i mean
so if you think of the the macro network
it's not that many people right
so it's basically the epi center was
probably
a few firms plus goldman and then you
know out of that
a bunch of traders of jp morgan a bunch
of others came out of that
but really it was tiger soros tudor
more capital caxton um
omega partners and a few others with the
big macro players
um and those alumni are everywhere so
dan moorhead is ex um
tiger i think he was ex-goldman as well
uh dan tapiero
was ex almost all of those um you know i
was ex
goldman and then i was running a large
hedge fund so i was a salesman at golden
so i knew everybody so i've been in the
middle of the whole lot
so we all know each other and if we
don't know each other
directly we know of each other because
it's not a big universe of people but
it had tremendous influence and huge
amounts of capital
um you know and it was a very exciting
industry because back in the day
these firms could have 15 20
volatility and had huge bets
so you'd get here famous people like
well famous in our world nick raditi who
was
actually the big swinging dick at soros
um he lived above a store in hampstead
high street in london
completely below the radar screen um
but he was the most aggressive risk
taker i've ever seen in the industry
even stan druckermiller says you know i
think nick
killed stan on returns but his
volatility
was enormous the size of the wrist this
older very quiet guy would take was
astonishing
so anyway so that macro world had high
risk taking and high returns
in came the pension funds in came the
insurance companies in came the
sovereign wealth funds
and they said well we don't want you to
be so risky and they're like
you're not going to get the returns
they're like well we don't really care
um so they crushed volatility down to
five percent
comes the rise of millennium and all of
these big platform plays
where they have lots of traders low
volatility
much lower returns you know 10 is a
great year
and so what happens is these macro guys
start either turning into family offices
lewis bacon from moore capital george
soros was first
um julian robertson i mean they all did
because they're like
[ __ ] that you know i want to make money
the old-fashioned way which is not by
having assets
it's by taking bets these guys are the
great speculators
and then some of those guys went this
bitcoin thing's interesting
now most didn't get it in the beginning
they saw it as a trade
and then everybody saw it started to see
it oh my god there's a parallel universe
coming
and it's all going to generate alpha
because there's no capital
and not enough knowledge in the space
because everybody in it was a
technologist
and none of these macro guys were in it
yet so the macro guys went
here's an opportunity for us and one by
one
they all start going have you seen this
you know
you know if you ask mark yusko if you
ask dan tapierro
um they will say that they really got
into this
at a global macro investor round table
of mine i think it was either in camera
in spain where one of the other global
macro guys another ex goldman hedge fund
guy
says by the way i started a crypto a
bitcoin exchange and you need to find
out about bitcoin this was 2012.
and we started learning about it from
them and that network then spreads
starts talking about it so we all kind
of got polluted at the same time
by similar people it is a network and
that pollution is you know so
cut to i get a phone call on sunday
uh one of the again i can't mention him
he's one of the most famous hedge fund
guys in the world
um and one of the greatest traders i've
ever seen
and he really made his money in money
markets he's a rates trader
right here's a world with no interest
rates so you know
and i've been bugging him about this i
mean he's been in crypto for a long time
he knows it but i was bugging him like
there's only one trade that matters and
the conversation on sunday is
yeah there's only one trade that matters
so when somebody like that who's got
world-class experience access to
enormous amounts of capital
uh i'll just kind of call it brass balls
in terms of the experience of taking big
bets with big volatility
what do they do when it clicks do they
go
let's go 90 into a position
or they kind of have their hands tied
because of who their lps are the fun
size the the position sizes and so they
may only be able to get you know 10 or
20
exposure and then they've got to figure
out what to do with the other 80 of the
bucket of capital firstly
he's a multi-billionaire that helps he
doesn't
it doesn't you know he doesn't need to
become
worth a hundred billion it's just it's
not relevant really
so it's the game now right it's it's the
game plus making sure that his capital
grows a reasonable amount without
blowing up
right that's the game once you've made
your billion you don't want to lose it
so yes so he he exactly as you said
um he's in slightly unusual situation i
can't reveal why because
everyone knows who he is then um but to
take an irresponsibly large bet within
the fund not
not easy to do for the lps and
everything else and the other reasons
but in his personal wealth and parts of
the portfolio you allocate to vc
you allocate to crypto itself
you allocate to other opportunities you
just get involved in the space and
you know a lot of people people like
john burbank
they did the same thing you know it get
involved in the space
you know you guys did the same thing
it's basically the same bet it's layer
on that bet in a number of different
ways
and then let's see where that goes
others
yeah i'm sure we're going to see people
taking more aggressive risks but most
people in a hedge fund structure can't
we will see one or two i'm sure there
are crypto hedge funds
out there that have done astonishingly
well anyway um i think a lot of those
are going to get bought so i was
speaking to a crypto hedge fund
so this is another part of what's going
on is they're all being bought
i mean again it's just consolidation of
kind of the new age hedge fund
being bought up or consolidated with the
older hedge funds who have lost the
ability to get volatility and drive
higher returns so let's go i mean look
look at a firm like
arca i always use arca because they're
super interesting because they're doing
a you know
tokens based kind of bottoms up
investing so up 300
right there's massive alpha in that
space you know everybody calls them [ __ ]
coins
nobody wants to be involved so you do
your homework you can make returns and
there's a ton of firms doing different
strategies
all got huge alpha the hedge fund
industry has no alpha it does nothing
it's excess capital too many machines
and restrictions on volatility
so there's massive alpha so these hedge
fund platforms are going
okay uncorrelated gigantic alpha
nobody's seen this a lot of the macro
guys will have seen it in the emerging
markets in the 80s and 90s
other than that we've not really seen it
in our careers but one thing that you're
mentioning here that i think is really
really important for people to
understand
is uh and you actually tweeted about
this uh and i loved it which was
look i belong in no group you can put no
label on me right
i basically look at charts and graphs
and assets and
and the macro environment and trends
data and metrics and then i make
decisions but you can't put me in a
bucket so
the labels don't fit and the reason why
i bring that up is
i heard from a very dear friend of mine
once that he said
you know steve cohen as an example could
sit down and look at a chart
regardless of what the asset was and
start trading it and be successful doing
it right
you just have some people who it doesn't
matter what the asset is what they're
looking for is the volatility they're
looking for
um you know all sorts of kind of market
structure things that they can then
exploit for profit right that's
basically what a lot of these traders
and
whether it was currencies or some other
commodity or whatever like that's what
they were doing
what i think is interesting is the
difference between
bitcoin and you know quote-unquote [ __ ]
coins and kind of the rest of the bucket
to somebody who is looking at it from a
um
a holding standpoint right or or an
ownership standpoint i put them in the
investor
uh or the saver category there is
massive massive difference you could
draw
a line in the sand that ends up you know
literally having tectonic plates shift
in the earth because they're so
different but when you look at it from a
pure
i'm a trader and i don't care if i'm
trading gold dollars
bitcoin or [ __ ] coin all i'm looking for
is volatility that i can capture returns
on all of a sudden now you start looking
for
where is the opportunity and i think
what i hear you saying is like it's
definitely not in the traditional assets
it's in this new world and then each
person has kind of preference or an
advantage in certain
assets within the new world that they're
going to go try to expose if they're a
trader
so well here's something interesting
about it is that's how it starts
and then they start understanding about
this new world now whether you anchor on
bitcoin or you anchor on some other
thing you'll anchor on something
of which you start building your
knowledge base same as you when you got
into the space same as
everybody does right so what happens is
they come into it for the trade
and stay for the future because we're
macro guys and
i say this a lot and people don't really
understand we live in the future
we look at possible futures and try and
predict them
based on everything from charts to flows
to fundamental analysis
and that's why they stay and that's why
they're agnostic
to the tribalism because what they're
saying is okay
we see this i don't care whether bitcoin
wins
i know that this whole space is going
somewhere and i want to be involved
and then you know so i've now got a
future framework and i'll trade
accordingly
and to come into it with a narrow
mindset
means that you won't be open to
opportunity
now maybe the bitcoin maximus are dead
right and bitcoin out forms everything
great the macro guys will also be on
that trend that's their job
to isolate that trend it's like
otherwise saying
well i'm a currency trader and you know
well i don't i'll only trade dolly yen
that's ludicrous nobody does that people
look for the opportunity
and then but these guys are bringing
real capital into the space too
because they are investing in startups
you know again
people philosophically say well it's you
know those speculators
they're just taking advantage of of this
whole kind of bitcoin philosophy
no they're not they're also feeding
capital they're bringing a lot of
capital
into businesses that are building on all
sorts of networks
some will fail some will succeed so
when we go back to kind of your asset
allocation having that perspective in
mind
um what's interesting is you were
bullish on
gold bitcoin um and kind of called
inflation hedge assets in general
uh you now have basically sold my
understanding as all of your gold
uh or majority of it and your 98
liquid net worth um allocated to bitcoin
and ethereum
uh i believe it's 80 bitcoin 20 ethereum
correct me if i'm wrong there
but just walk us through why sell gold
to increase the exposure is it there's
just more upside and stronger conviction
in the trade is it something that
happened in gold
i think gold goes up but bitcoin's gonna
go up
a lot more it's that moment when you
have the light bulb moment is
you know [ __ ] it there's a time to stand
up and be counted this is your
opportunity
now could i be wrong of course but it's
this looked to me like the best single
macro opportunity i'd seen in my entire
life and
you know i've seen a few good ones you
know i had a great one with a bond trade
you know last year and
early into this year and stuff like that
but this is better than that this is
this is a once in a lifetime bet and
kind of
when you look at those charts you see
gold breaking down versus bitcoin and
stuff like that you think i understand
portfolio diversification i understand
why it's important for many people but i
can i'm in a position where i can take
this bet because a i have income streams
b i don't have any debt um
and so therefore and i'm not using
leverage
so therefore if it all goes tits up i'm
fine
but it's a very very big but i've never
taken a bet this big
so one of my questions was gonna be have
you ever done something like this before
so that's good to know the second thing
is there's a lot
of people asking when you say liquid net
worth
do you consider when you put trades on
the percentage of liquid net worth and
total net worth
or do you just think of it in kind of
the constraints of what your liquid net
worth and
the percentages of an individual trading
i don't run my life like a portfolio i
think it's wrong and i know people do
this concentration on total net worth i
explain that more why you don't yeah so
i
it depends what you're in this game for
i'm not in this game for money
money is a lifestyle token and for me
what i care about is my quality of life
and again i'm not talking about i need
to have a
jet order it's about the quality of life
you know
can i can i live in a beautiful house
can i afford to eat at a nice restaurant
can i
do certain things and so for me the
primary important thing for me is where
i live
and property that i have that i use i
don't rent
anything out that i have they're mine
and they increase my quality of life
and so that's what i'm looking for
and so i don't think of i need to grow
my net worth
i'm lucky i've made some money i've
gotten
what i want now
so then the speculation for me is a the
intellectual challenge but b
you want to make sure you've got enough
money to survive and do things and you
know because there's always something
you need to do you know i need to do a
ton of work on the house in grand cayman
and that sucks up a ton of money and
you know all of that stuff um
and that's how i think of it i just
think of it as as
tokens and if you get rich enough then
you probably give up with that game and
you go and do something that you think
is worthy
because you only got one life and if
it's not it's not all about making money
it's about
having the best quality of life that you
can possibly achieve for yourself and
your family
absolutely twenty percent into ether
uh or ethereum um explain kind of what
the thesis there is is it a market
structure thing it's a smaller market
cap and therefore if everything goes up
it should go up more
is it uh something around kind of the
value and the technology
what's driving uh the interest there's a
hunch
that i have and it's only a hunch hence
why it's a much smaller position
there's a hunch that from all of my
conversations
around this whole space that there is a
massive amount of human cap intellectual
capital working in that particular space
because it's the flexibility of of how
ethereum is based and there's a load of
flaws like there's floors about
everything so
you know i'm not saying it's a perfect
well i also don't think of bitcoin and
ethereum as the same thing
bitcoin to me is this pristine
collateral it's
you know it's perfect i don't need now
whether everybody builds the lightning
layer and all the other stuff on top
great i own tons of bitcoin
but i see the amount of intellectual
capital that's going into the ethereum
space and i'm thinking
there's a chance that something really
really big comes out of this
and so i think of it as a platform
and it's a very crude way of looking at
it but if i see a lot of people all
building on one platform then the
probability
you know as a vc the probability of one
of those bets paying off huge
let's say d5 ends up being on there and
it becomes a real thing
whatever it may be who the hell knows
could be intellectual property rights i
don't know
don't care the point being is i think
there's a chance that ethereum can have
a larger market cap than bitcoin
and that doesn't make it a better
currency or a better investment
it's because by the nature of a platform
versus an asset
you know gold is the purest form of
money that we've had
and it's a 10 trillion dollar asset the
currency markets trade
4 trillion a day and they're not
they're not in any way the same shape or
form but it's a bigger platform because
more people use it
so the currency market overall is worth
more so i just think of it in those
terms and again it's a very macro way of
looking at it which is
not interested in the fight between the
technologies and what trey believes and
what and how many coins can you measure
and
what's the sub total supply it's like
okay
there is a chance here that this does
really well but
i don't have enough conviction to make
that my large bet
my large bet is bitcoin because i have
full conviction got it and so
uh one of the things that's so
interesting whether it's you or other
macro investors
the common theme is uh obviously courage
conviction but also open-mindedness and
i think that
one of the things that uh crypto
probably doesn't do a good job of
is encourage the open-mindedness right
it's very kind of tribal
uh whoever is right wrong whatever it's
just a full out frankly kind of
intellectual war it's like this war of
attrition
uh when it comes to ideas which there is
very strong benefits
and there's some healthy nature to that
but when you look at it from a pure
kind of trading and investment
standpoint having the open mind to
uh read things look at things understand
new things
is really important and so how do you
one stay open-minded as you get older
you get more experience you kind of have
seen things and you don't fall into the
trap of like i've seen this before or i
know how this is gonna work or i'm the
smart person in the room
are there things that you do content
that you consume like how do you keep an
open mind
kind of year after year after year for
long periods of time one thing i've
learned
is
you need to think more about human
behavior and incentives and why people
are doing things so as you alluded to
why is it so tribal it's actually a
throwback to 2016
when there was a lot of these projects
rising nobody knew who was going to win
everyone put their money in them and you
want your own to win right it's like
going to the horse races and saying
sports teams right and that war is still
being forced and it's a false narrative
now
because bitcoin's dominance as what it
is
is now established it's clear it's
institutionalized it's
it's all that's over so does it matter
about
the rise of these other things that
they're not in competition with each
other
but human behavior is driving that and i
think as a macro guy
it's actually to my advantage because if
you call it [ __ ] coins
i want to know about it because i know
there's opportunity
because you're being dumb and you're
being done not that
you might be right but you've got a
closed mind
and if i'm up against somebody with a
closed mind i can find an edge
and that's how i look at this and i look
at this whole space and i see it's a
very narrative driven space
it's all behavioral driven so use that
behavior to your advantage
because within that is something
interesting i'm also intellectually
interested in the future
because that's what i do and if somebody
tells me not to look at ripple i will go
and look at ripple because you will not
tell me what to do
and i will find out myself what its
flaws and what its potential benefits
are and assess the probability myself
i may reach exactly the same conclusions
as you i may
reach a completely different conclusion
but imagine if i do and i don't own
ripple i don't know i'm not getting into
that fight but
let's assume i think it's got a 10
chance of becoming something much bigger
but the whole market is giving it a half
a percent chance
without misalignment in risk reward it's
a huge opportunity
that's what we do in financial markets
we have to remain open
you know you can't trade financial
markets and go well i'm only going to
trade apple
and every other company is a fraud
they're not as good because their phones
aren't as good i mean it's ridiculous
what we look for is okay where is the
secular trend change
what's the best vehicle to express that
view in can i diversify
that view can i add juice to that view
can i create alpha around that view so
that's
that's why i come at it and i think all
the macro guys you know
dan tapiara we all kind of exactly the
same way dan moorhead
we just we discovered it differently and
i understand that some of the
crypto community doesn't like that
because it feels like we're kind of
abusive of the space but
you know much like i talked about with
regulation i get people upset when i say
regulation's a good thing
um well if you want to get rich
people kind of have to come into the
space and talking
you know i joke about this talking about
cyber hornets
i'm sorry it's not going to bring a
single corporate treasurer or a single
institutional asset allocator into this
game and if you want to get rich
you need those guys to come into the
game it's a really difficult thing
because people don't
don't want the traditional financial
markets in this space but they need it
for it to go up
it's kind of weird well and i think one
of the things that uh you're really
describing here is kind of the um
the trend of technology adoption right
there's kind of these different groups
of people that
uh adopt things and so you know the most
extreme example
is pretty much every electronic based
technology was adopted by criminals
first whether it was beeper cell phones
you know
vpns all this kind of stuff now they
were doing it because they were
constantly playing
a cat and mouse game with police right
or law enforcement
and eventually that stuff gets
normalized and accepted in the
mainstream
and so i don't see anyone walking around
being like ah cell phones those are bad
those criminals they started using the
cell phones first
right bitcoin for a while that was the
narrative was oh
criminals use it now i think we're kind
of escaping that and people are
realizing hey this isn't just about
criminal activity or anything like that
so
there's pros to the adoption the one
thing though is that many of the people
who are early
right and if it works they get
financially rewarded for being early and
having the courage of conviction to do
it
but it also the narrative does change
right
and to your point the narrative has to
change for some people to come in
and you get almost now uh kind of the
suits versus
um you know the the uh well look
you know what it's like with music right
when you you say oh yeah you know i love
xyz radiohead i like them in their early
days right that's the standard line
and it's the same thing nobody wants it
to change because they want to have it
as they want it to be
as they see it the problem is this is a
network it's a live
living breathing thing the narrative is
going to change the space is going to
change and there's
nothing you or i can do about it and
that's the beauty of it
that's the beauty of a distributed
network is
it's nothing down to us we're irrelevant
in the picture
all we can do is is get involved a lot
involved as simple as that
for sure speaking of getting involved uh
institutions
seem to uh be racing each other to uh to
get in
on uh on the trade or get exposure um i
joke and say that
uh obviously you know kind of retail or
individuals were first probably one of
the first times in history
that uh one of the best if not the best
trade in a decade
uh individuals beat wall street to the
trade right and that's hard for a lot of
people to comprehend from the media to
large asset allocators
uh even to some individual uh investors
now what we're seeing though is it's
almost becoming
cool or becoming necessary to have a
bitcoin strategy and so it started with
a lot of kind of the macro
investors that we've already talked
about then we started to see a couple of
corporate treasuries
now it seems like every large
institutional investor on wall street
whether it's guggenheim
whether it's larry fink from blackrock
everyone is commenting about it and it's
hard to understand
kind of how serious some of them are
right some other actually changing
documents and
positioning themselves to get exposure
others are saying ah maybe it can become
something which isn't quite as far
how do you view the institutional
interest right now and then let's talk
through kind of sequentially once an
institution says
we need to do this what is that process
gonna look like and is that something
that happens quickly or is that still a
six to twelve month exercise
uh for capital to flow into the space so
um
before i get into a lot of that you
raise the uh
used terminology that i've used for
seven six years in this space seven
years
which is everybody now has a bitcoin
strategy
so i've talked about this and i talked
about a long time ago
is from what i could see um
what i could see is there was a number
of these narratives that happened
to all corporates at the same time so i
saw
it in in in the late 90s is
we need to have an internet strategy and
before that was obviously a computer
strategy but
from my career it's like we need to have
an internet strategy
then 2003 it's like oh god we need a
china strategy
right so everybody piled into china
then 2010 it became oh we need a social
media strategy
as social media kind of took over the
world and then we've had in the last
four years we've had probably a split
between we need to have a video strategy
which is one of the reasons we set up
real vision and the other one is
probably an ai strategy
data big data strategy and i've been
saying for years
the next one to come is we're going to
need to have a bitcoin strategy
you know or it's a blockchain strategy
or whatever the whole space is
so that is happening right so that's a
rolling process
as the adoption of technology continues
at a relentless pace
so from the
conversations i've had it's usually a
passionate person
internally so there's a passionate
person at the largest family office
one of the largest family offices i know
i can't remember can't explain where it
is because they'll give it away
um and he's been writing white papers
for the head of the family
about bitcoin because
that guy can make massive change and
you see that adoption it takes a it's a
fight we all
all those people have to fight
internally because
somehow you need to get other people and
a group of people involved
that's going on then on the other side
of it we've got the market cap going up
so at 100 billion dollars nobody cared
at 300 billion dollars
it matters at a trillion dollars i need
to be involved
so suddenly if it's a trillion dollars i
need to get involved with the supply
constraints in this thing
um it's a five trillion dollar asset
before you know it
um so that is going on
they are all having the conversation but
this is what i've been talking about and
i'm doing something about it myself now
is this community doesn't speak the
language of those people
it's like me screaming at you in french
and you're like i don't understand you
you know
we've got to stop speaking in terms of
bitcoin philosophy and all of this stuff
if you want adoption if you don't and
you just want to talk about that stuff
that's fine too
so what are those what language should
we need to speak
we need to speak the language of and
i've talked about this barra b
a double r a risk modeling that's an
msci owned product there's a couple of
other products like it
which is what all the big asset
allocators use for modeling risk
and deciding what assets and how they
fit in a portfolio right nobody talks
this language
nobody talks about kind of the full
correlation analysis and all of these
things and portfolio effects
that needs to happen corporate
treasurers they need another set of
stuff and this is why and if this is
going to annoy everybody
this is what investment bankers are so
good at investment bankers
are the people who know how to speak to
these people
what is happening is the investment
banks are starting to talk about this
and i'm getting phone calls
you know on a personal level many of
them are involved structural level
they're not ready yet
but those bankers are coming out of
banks leaving them and saying okay i can
help so
you know i'm speaking to another guy
today from a firm in the u.s
super interesting um setting up a
they're just kind of launching
um but it's big and it's all based
around custody and brokerage for all of
these wealthy families and these
institutions
based out new york um they're hiring
these investment bankers
because they know exactly how to speak
to asset managers so
those conversations will happen and i'm
trying to get a paper written by a real
vision
uh member who happens to have been one
of the guys who worked at barrow and all
of this risk
because i've been reaching out i said
can i help i said yes please
can you just write me the paper that we
all need to circulate to everybody
to drive the next phase of of helping
these people get these people across the
line so
yeah and so why is everyone's mind
changing
all at once right whether it is
individuals whether it's macro investors
institutions now you see even
governments and corporations i mean
everyone seems to be talking about this
and
one of the the frameworks that i use is
bitcoin is
very quickly transitioning from
contrarian trade to consensus trade
and obviously in that transition if you
are in before the transition
that tends to usually be a good thing uh
because the consensus trade is kind of
what drives uh the us dollar price of an
asset um but what is it is it the macro
environment
is it just the lights clicked and the
career risk is taken away and now
stanley druckenmiller and ptj
are in or what is it all of those are
signals
the actual things were is all of us are
uneasy
we've been uneasy since the financial
crisis and probably since
2000 anybody involved in financial
markets has had a sense of unease
we've also had a sense of optimism about
technology
and here are those things meeting here's
the technological solution
to the unease that we've been feeling
and so i think that's why it's
resonating and people come from
different angles whether they're
technology
this is an amazing future or like this
is all [ __ ] i need something to help
me
the life raft all of those people are
coming together that's quite super
narrative and
i think it's dead right as well i mean
this is why i mean when i look through
the other side
i think we're going to this is a fourth
turning moment
i think the entire financial structure
of the world is
in flux and if this moment gets seized
upon
properly everything will change now it
doesn't mean we'll come up with a
perfect answer
maybe bitcoin ends up being the solution
at the very end but we've got a lot
between here and the very end to go i
mean that's a couple of decades
so walk me out um kind of in your
mind 10 years from now 15 years from now
what does that look like is it the hyper
bitcoinization
that kind of hardcore bitcoiners would
describe is it something else
like when you look out and you're
talking to uh one of your macro investor
friends or a family office or an
institution they say
hey you got a lot of money allocated to
this
investment where are we going how do you
answer that
okay so the gateways that i'm looking
for on a very macro perspective
is okay we've seen the fintech layer
being built
we've seen the banks kind of go okay
this is going to happen
what do we have to do we've seen capsule
coming into the space to allow these
people to build stuff
we've seen a various different platforms
and different solutions to different
problems
and solutions to problems that aren't
problems either so we've seen that okay
so that's great that's where we are now
so what's the next big catalyst next big
catalyst
in prices institutions but they're not
what's driving this space
the next part because it's it's the
disruption of money that's going on
the next part is what the central banks
are screaming at everybody is
they are going to change money and my
belief in that is they are going to
change money not only just in the basket
that we talked about
or some way shape or form but they're
also going to change monetary and fiscal
policy forever
they're going to blend so central banks
will be able to do direct stimulus
now that means the rise of behavioral
economics
which has been used in silicon valley
for a long time facebook's built on it
network effects metcasten all they're
all the same thing
that is going to come into this space so
that means
they can penalize you with negative one
percent interest rates because you're a
saver
and give a student positive interest
rates or they could they could do
anything they want within programmable
money
now benoit curry from the xccb now the
bis
talks about this openly that the central
banks are going to go down two different
paths
some will just have an additional
currency which is just digital fiat
but it allows much easier transfer and
others will do programmable smart money
and clearly people like the ecb are very
interested in programmable smart money
because they've got a banking system
that doesn't work velocity of money
around the world is zero
less than one so monetary mechanism
doesn't work
so you need to change everything i mean
they're literally going to change
everything i think what you're talking
about and i don't think people really
understand this but this is uh this is
you know level 401 501 in the college
course right but
is essentially having monetary policy
customized
and personalized to the individual level
and people can't
think about that because they've never
seen it before but i
it sounds like you do as well fully
believe that that is coming
and it is part surveillance state it is
part
uh you know super powers for central
bank it is part technology advancement
like all these trends coming together
but this idea that i can actually treat
you differently than your neighbor
is the dream of a central bank it's
also look if i was given the same set of
issues
let's say we're not going to get rid of
central banks and go to bitcoin
overnight and i'll come on to that
process
so let's say i want to solve the
problems that we've got now
this is genius this is literally
genius because if you have big data sets
and behavioral economics you can do some
really
really powerful things now
the flip side is it's terrifying because
it can be used nefariously and
governments are governments and they
will edge towards that we get that right
i'm not saying
that it's good but it is also extremely
good
if we had this in place through this
crisis we just had all the last crisis
we would have solved it so much faster
what interests me again if that is not
what my opinion is
it's is it going to happen and what do
we do
and again people just get angry about it
i'm like you can get angry all you want
if it if it rains tomorrow you can get
angry about it but it's raining
whether you like it or not deal with
what is this is coming
in one way shape or form so okay we're
now in the central bank digital currency
world we're five years out that's when
it's gonna it's gonna happen within five
years right so the world's changing it's
a
big explosion the central banks have all
said
we want private sector to build out the
fintech layer
happy with decentralized finance happy
with bitcoin we just regulate people
on and off ramps make sure everybody can
use it let's go right that's that's
what's the stage has been said
[Music]
so then what's the next stage well this
is all for it money still
and governments are government so
they're going to use it for nefarious
means over time and we're going to get a
bit more uneasy again about it
so what are we going to do well there'll
be some latin american countries bored
of having currency crisis after currency
crisis say
well you know what i'm going to put
bitcoin into my
reserve because bitcoin at this point is
probably 10 trillion
plus asset you know that's when i think
it's worth a million dollars
um so five six years time so some
country costa rica goes you know we're
going to hold our reserves in bitcoin
and then and then they get rewarded for
it like like michael sailor's just been
rewarded for putting it into his company
right it's the same process
and behaviorally and game theory will
tell you that everybody else will start
doing it
so then you have hard currencies versus
other currencies and it puts pressure on
those other current and so that's the
process that can lead
can lead to hyper bit colonization
yeah does it get there who knows but
that's the process
i want to throw out one um kind of
variation to the scenario because i
think what you just described is what
i'll call the central bank perspective
like how does the central bank
eventually adopt it and we get to hyper
bitcoinization
but one uh kind of stepping stone in
that direction that i've started to
think a lot about and i want your
opinion on
is um actually switching
cost and friction between currencies is
very high right now
if i have dollars and i want euros uh
for most people that means like
literally going to the airport going to
a currency changer and getting ripped
off and like
exchanging money right i mean like at
the most basic level
or fundamental level for the majority of
people like that is
currency trading right or exchanging
obviously as you get to more
sophisticated levels of the financial
sector
uh that can become easier less friction
but for the everyday person
it is super high cost and super uh high
friction in order to change currencies
well if all of a sudden all of the
currencies are digitized you have a
digital dollar digital euro yen all you
know
everything and you have bitcoin and you
have everything else
and the adoption of digital wallets goes
through the roof because now everyone
needs a digital wallet
we're going to enter this world where
the switching cost is the click of a
button
so i can go from dollars to bitcoin to
euro back to bitcoin to dollars
with literally just the click of a
button and so one of the things that
also going along this lines of kind of
customization or personalization of
monetary policy is
we've all have this mentality that uh
you do everything in the same currency
in your life and the only time that i
would go from dollars to another
currencies if i'm traveling
but is there a world where maybe what we
see is the united states says hey we
want dollars for taxes for example or
you have to make payments
but if i'm not actually spending if i'm
not conducting a payment
i will keep my wealth in bitcoin for
example right so i use it as a store of
value and then when i want to come out
all of a sudden i click a button i you
know immediately transition into the
dollar or digital dollar and then i
spend it
and so you now can almost get into this
multi-currency type
uh modality that allows people not to be
siloed or kind of confined to a single
currency in their life
they can now use currencies for
different purposes
based on the advantages or disadvantages
that that currency and that monetary
policy provides
but i don't hear people talking about
that and maybe it's just because that
world's never going to happen i don't
know
that's how every family office lives
every single family office
has done that for 50 years
they have a base currency where they
have their expenses or their cash flow
let's say they still own a business
many of them will choose gold as a base
asset
and they'll switch around currencies
accordingly for interest rate
differentials
or other advantages so that is normal
it's just not normal for average people
because the friction costs
are too high but for wealthy families
it's normal for hedge funds it's normal
for asset allocators it's normal
so yes i think that's right um
i think gold i've always
talked about as a personal reserve asset
but it's it's clunky by
actual physical definition it's clunky
right but bitcoin as you say
i got my wallet i keep everything in
bitcoin i flip it in and out of what
where i need it
pay my taxes i have to go to the store
store doesn't use bitcoin because
they're in the tax system
fine that's no that's no problem um and
i think that is part of the world
that we will adopt it because it has
uses for us
but that's the same use that the costa
rica or whoever adopts it for the same
reason
and that's it's that process of choosing
it as a base currency for everybody
that happens over time behaviorally just
because
survivor takes the winner takes all
essentially but but yes people are going
to get used to this
and again they have no understanding
what's coming people just
don't understand the amount of
tokenization that's about to happen
all right you are one of the most
intellectually honest and open-minded
people i know
so i've been looking forward all day to
ask you this question i want you to flip
around on the table
and argue against your bull position
what is the bear case for bitcoin
and what would have to happen for you to
change your mind install your bitcoin
firstly and obviously price action
and that's not you know oh i'm raoul
gets scared as the mean you know don't
scare rowell
we can't we can't roll it's like
it's like if there is a structural
change in the
pattern here's something i've been
thinking about that i don't think
anybody's thinking through right
come all in institutional investors
right we want you in
okay but then we've got a problem is
we're going to have to start dealing
with
month-end rebalances quarter and
rebalances where they become massive
sellers if bitcoin goes up 100
in a month which we've seen many times
in the past they end up selling
50 of their bitcoin okay that's suddenly
a massive supply change to the market
so maybe the structure of the market
changes in a way that doesn't have the
risk reward that we're all expecting
because we're all a bit backward looking
you know i look at that i look at the
my price projections from a number of
different angles but maybe the structure
of bringing
institutions in changes entirely
in which case the volatility gets
massively dampened the price
spikes get dampened and in which case
you don't really outperform let's say
emerging markets
that's a that's a possibility that's out
there that people aren't thinking
through
the more liquid at market the less the
volatility the less the upside
the upside is so big right now because
nobody's in it
now are there other market structure
things that you would put alongside that
so that's one kind of
red flag or thing to watch are there
other things that you would put in that
category i would say that if
china nationalized the miners or did
something
something completely outside of our
expectations
before we can diversify the mining pool
i know people are trying to build it off
gas flows in texas and other stuff which
is great
if something happened there where
somebody could control it which i don't
believe can happen but
yeah all sorts of things i don't believe
can happen can happen um
so there's something something there
would make me concerned
you know if i thought about what freaks
me out in 2017 and why i got out early
was people started forking the thing and
we didn't know where the forks are going
to
work or not were they going to take off
the liquidity and ruin the whole thing
i didn't know so i'm like i'm out so
something of that kind of nature would
make me think i don't know what that is
but you know there's a lot of smart
people developing a lot of things and
who knows what comes along obviously
regulation should the regulators
completely change
course all i see is positive regulation
but if the imf stood up and said we've
agreed to move to the central bank
digital currencies
and as part of that every member of this
basket
has banned all cryptocurrencies
and they come with prison sensors
whatever yeah clearly i'm going to
change my
well well i don't know but well i
changed my mind not changed my mind it
kind of makes
a better case for bitcoin but you know
there's two arguments there the price
goes down or actually the price explodes
upwards
yeah i kind of value my freedom and i
value my freedom i don't want to get
into prison
and still be monetarily free so i don't
know
um so it's difficult it's difficult and
that makes me nervous when i can't find
anything obvious but my guess is
with a strong powerful force like this
whatever will stop it is not obvious
which is why i thought
maybe just the flows from institutions
where like the hedge fund game when i
started was 15
volatility and now it's six percent
volatility and
you know maybe maybe it changes and then
it becomes a different game if that's
the game then the game is built
applications on top
as fast as you can once the volatility
dies down you can do anything with it
because it becomes less of a speculative
asset and it becomes an exchangeable
asset
it becomes money basically more money so
so and i think that that is
uh if you were to ask kind of the
believers of bitcoin so not traders who
are just looking from a financial return
perspective for people who hold it and
believe you know it's the next global
reserve currency etc
this idea of the transition of
narratives kind of the end game is
it is a stable asset that uh can be used
as a
medium of exchange and a store of value
part of what you're
almost describing is like there's this
trade-off between uh
if i am a trader and volatility gets
dampened
that's a negative but if i am a holder
and i believe it's gonna be the next
global reserve currency that dampening
of volatility
actually furthers my argument that it
should be the next global order of
currency right
like there's this yin and yang almost at
play between those two things
and that's right right because what
we're trading is the adoption cut
that's all we're doing we're just
trading metcalfe's law right it's doing
this
we're trading this the top of the curve
is called adoption
that's and that's okay everyone has to
play their part in that
and the end of it could be that bitcoin
is the world reserve currency
okay we have to change the entire
current global mechanism to for that to
happen
great we can all make money doing that
too because people are going to be
building businesses
there's a whole world of stuff out there
but
um you know for me looking that far out
i'm interested in it
i think it may happen i think there's a
reasonable probability over time i don't
know how long that time is
and all i do know is from here to now is
a long time
absolutely another question that a lot
of people had was
uh you've got this massive position
right from a percentage base of your
liquid net worth what are the triggers
uh that would
uh you would look to to sell so in a
bowl case the price goes up
uh there's certain events that happen so
one is just like what would cause you to
sell or
incentivize you to sell and then two is
how would you
structurally go about that is that a
single trigger
i'm going to sell my entire position or
is that i'm going to sell into a bull
market
how do you think about it basically the
answer is well i talked about lifestyle
tokens
okay i am actually taking another huge
risk
i built and run a business and that's
been a risky
hard-working enterprise and i don't take
any money out of that business i've got
extremely small salary
so for me i have foregone current
returns
for future returns so if bitcoin goes up
a lot i'll take some chips off the table
and so then i can know okay fine
anything happens i'm safe i've always
trade from position of security and then
i just run the rest
now yes could i say i would probably
scale out over price objectives
and hold the core position over time
because i i do think it goes a lot
further up
um over time and so you know can i
suffer the downside will it be as large
will it be a
90 downside this time highly unlikely
it'll look more like a commodity cycle
so probably 50 60
but it could be you know the usual three
or four years and you know
i would happily participate in that you
know and just not worry about it
if i took some chips off the table
everybody's safe i can do what i want to
do
and i don't have to worry what are the
charts or metrics when you wake up every
morning that you check first
right and i think of that as kind of the
things you check when you first wake up
have the highest level of importance or
signal
what are those things for you so next
time is my bloomberg
screen so i mean my bloomberg screen is
one whole group is all stock markets and
i actually don't look at them a lot well
i i kind of do but i don't really care
because i
i don't even understand any longer
they're so driven by human behavior
whatever i look at the bond market
because the bond market is the truth of
what's going on the underlying economy
so it's always useful
quick check of bond yields going up or
down anything going on
quick check commodity markets just
because again there's somewhere between
sentiment and bonds
they're kind of economic but slightly
and then i check
uh currency markets which i include
bitcoin as one of my currency positions
so that's what i i just very quickly
glance that
okay so now i know what's going on then
i go to the news
so i start start with twitter unless
you've been on my feed
asking questions and i'm like [ __ ] i
can't even look at anything on it so
that i'll flip to the ft
and you know flick through some
headlines or bloomberg and when my
twitter feed is cleared up i'll go back
through it
and be able to read uh what's going on
because twitter is a great hive mind i
also use the real vision exchange
there's some really smart people on
there um i'll then go and see what
content was out on real vision that
morning
and you know i'm up early so usually
i'll i'll
watch a video on real vision
go through this go through my email go
through all the markets all between kind
of five and
six five and six thirty in the morning
you mentioned real vision it has become
one of
if not the go-to resource for kind of
macro
content for those that don't know uh
real vision is basically uh take all the
great aspects of youtube
but uh bring the smartest people in
finance on and basically they interview
each other and so you can imagine the
quality of the information
uh the insight and just kind of what you
can glean from that
uh how has it gone so far and kind of
talked to us about the growth this year
the launch of the crypto
division i guess you would call it um
and kind of how you
view the progress of real vision so far
yeah i mean real one of the premises
behind real business
is that financial sense of unease
you know it was all within all of us
and i knew that people needed better
information so that was the premise
behind it democratize that information
don't just give it to hedge fund guys
like me
let's give it to everybody so that was
the idea um
and that premise obviously came to life
over this period
is like everyone needs to know um so
that's been great that's really
helped change me i get emails every
single day i mean walls of emails
linkedin messages twitter
thanking us for doing what we've done to
empower people
so that's been great we launched a
community because people want to speak
to each other because they're a really
smart group of people
our users our members are
the learning tribe i did a thing i asked
them to make a video to say about who
they
are because i didn't really know you've
got this breakdown of you know
52 u.s and 45 financial market
professionals like who the hell are
these people
amazing we've got like 300 videos we've
got
neuroscientists in south korea doing
neuroscience
while watching real vision video
listening on his ear pods
one of the guys working on the biggest
telescope in the world in the atacama
desert
a astrophysicist is watching real vision
while he's waiting for the stars to come
out to
taxi driver i mean but they all come
with knowledge so
that whole community thing is exploding
for us
um and then so the business is doing you
know really really well for us
and we're just becoming a kind of a
center of this community
of the financial community and that's
great where we all kind of work
together like you know i'll come on your
podcast you'll come real vision we all
part of the same community and real
estate is
becoming the kind of meeting place for
all of that
and many people came to us and said you
need to do something in crypto because
one thing about real vision was we're
unbiased
i may have a view but i'm not real
vision real vision is you coming on and
talking to somebody else or
you know one person interviewing another
it's it's it's a broad
exchange of views so somebody said
listen we've got a problem in the crypto
space
we need to be able to talk the language
area of institutions
we also be need to be less tribal and
more understanding of each other of
what's really going on out there
because this is a broad shift and many
big players came to us and said can you
do something about this
so we decided that we would launch
something in the spirit of crypto we
thought we'd do it free
and the only way of solving for free was
working with some of the you know best
partners in the world so we
we've done with block fire and
silvergate and we just
announced another sponsor but basically
we've created real vision all over again
but just crypto and that's every aspect
of this from bitcoin maximalist to
people doing weird little applications
somewhere everything
because we want to just make sure that
the playing field is leveled
just because you were in early doesn't
mean you get all the chances that's not
fair because that's the same as the
financial markets were before
what it is here is we're democratizing
this too and get everybody into the
space and it's been
amazing i mean we only launched a week
ago and we've got 50 000 people on the
platform already
it's crazy yeah it's huge and people and
and
i love the internet man it's
amazing it's amazing so you know it's uh
it's growing fast but real vision itself
even the youtube
the standard youtube channel we're now
400 000 subscribers and like
three million views a month and podcasts
our podcast now does
650 000 downloads a month and we're
launching four more podcasts
we're launching education as well we've
got whole education tiers coming free
within the content so
not only because again you and i know a
lot of people don't understand what
we're talking about
so what we're building in is education
into all those membership tiers
that's free world-class knowledge so you
can get your education and then get the
content to help you
figure out what's going on makes so much
sense all right before we wrap
up i want to play a rapid fire game with
you i'm going to throw out a word or a
phrase
and you just mind dump on me whatever
comes to mind
ready yeah first up is bitcoin
winning ethereum
interesting xrp
central banks net sellers of gold
boring stanley druckenmiller
legend
federal reserve boring
janet yellen
you can do multiple words
interesting to see where this goes
that's a central banker
running running fiscal policy which is
what i was talking about before
and lastly financial markets
under abiding administration
same as it's ever been it's pretty good
where can people find you on the
internet and find out more about real
vision
yeah find me on twitter i'm always
hanging around causing trouble or
answering questions
you know i do get involved so at raul
r-a-o-u-l
gmi and um real vision crypto because
there's a lot of people watching this
crypto people
just real vision crypto.com or just go
to the home page and click on the crypto
bit
and it's free so just stick in your
email and your wall to wall
a fire hose of content listen man
as always it's a pleasure we're gonna
have to do this again and hopefully next
time we do it
uh we will not be in covid uh time so we
can do it again in person
yeah we'll get you to cayman next time
i'm definitely gabe
peter mccormick's coming so perfect
that's right